these secret files offer a rare glimpse
at iran's alleged ambitions for new
cyber attacks
possible targets include cargo ships and
petrol stations
britain the united states and france
among countries of apparent interest
the uk's defense secretary says if
authentic
the documents show how vulnerable the
real world is to attacks from cyberspace
unless we do something about it our
critical infrastructure
our way of life can be threatened quite
easily
and you know there are states out there
who are very active
in mapping hacking looking for
vulnerabilities
the five separate reports are marked
very confidential
and written by intelligence team 13
allegedly a secret iranian cyber group
they're not all dated but this one is
from the iranian calendars equivalent
of the 19th of november last year
most of the files start with a quote
apparently from iran's supreme leader
saying the islamic republic of iran must
become
among the world's most powerful in the
area of cyber
the papers then reveal fairly basic
research
into various civilian sectors including
here
the ballast water system on cargo ships
this diagram
shows how it helps a vessel to balance
or cap size if manipulated
it says any kind of disruptive influence
can cause significant
and irreparable damage to the vessel
another document
looks at a system that monitors fuel at
a petrol station
it notes how a cyber hack on the
automatic tank gauge
could cut off fuel supply or even cause
an explosion
iran was linked in 2017 to a cyber
attack on the uk parliament
thousands of email accounts were
targeted including those of mps
now these five documents appear to show
evidence of iranian cyber research into
other areas of civilian life
the source who shared them with me said
he believes the cell that compiled this
data
is creating a target bank to be used
whenever they see fit
the security source said intelligence
team 13
is part of a branch known as shahid cave
that's within the islamic revolutionary
guard course cyber command
iran's embassy in the uk did not respond
to a request for comment on the files
but tehran has in the past denied
allegations of cyber attacks
the general in charge of the uk's cyber
weapons
isn't surprised iran wants to boost its
cyber power
among the most advanced
cyber actors so we take their their
capabilities
seriously we don't um we don't over
state it but we
you know they're a serious actor and
they have behaved really irresponsibly
in the past
as these files indicate they may also be
seeking to pose a threat
in the future debra haynes sky news